And now, I'd like to imp- to- to present today's speakers.
Victoria Woo Ph.D is a lecturer at Stanford University,
and an entrepreneur with more than 25 years of experience in startups,
international management and academia.
Victoria has devoted the past decade to bridging academia and business by
co-designing custom executive programs at INSEAD and Harvard,
where she helped Fortune 500 clients curate
learning journeys for C-suite leaders and high-potential .
In these roles, Victoria has also facilitated dialogue and cooperation
among worldwide business partners, alumni, and clients.
Since returning from a decade working in Asia,
Victoria has served as a mentor for Blackbox.vc,
a non-profit organization serving
the global entrepreneurial ecosystem and as an advisor for early-stage startups.
Victoria is now working on a sixth startup,
which is focused on increasing engagement in the sense of community among hourly workers.
Joining Victoria today is Lynda Smith,
a lecturer in Global Entrepreneurial Marketing at Stanford University and
a marketing and sales executive with more than 25 years of experience.
Lynda has spent the last 15 years in high-technology products and services as the SVP of
marketing or CMO for a number of companies
including Genesys Telecommunication Laboratories,
Nuance, Genpact and Jive Software.
In these roles, Ly- Lynda has successfully laid
virtually every marketing function including product marketing,
product management, corporate marketing, field marketing,
regeneration, channel marketing, marketing research and strategy development,
all driving marketing in the US, Europe,
India, China and other major markets.
Lynda has an undergraduate degree in liberal arts from Simpson College,
and an MBA from the Wharton School of Business at the University of Pennsylvania.
Her current area of interest is what is happening in this next generation of marketing,
where digital media and social networks are combining
to reshape the art and science of marketing.
Professors, the floor is yours.
[NOISE] Good morning everyone.
Um, just some little- something about what we do at MSNA 271,
uh, Global Entrepreneurial Marketing is effectively what it is.
I'll start with global,
then entrepreneurial, then marketing.
Um, what we do is we introduce the core, uh,
marketing concept to bring a new product or service to,
er, market, but also help you build it to its success.
Uh, we go towards its both en- entrepreneurs and intrapreneurs, uh, from the pool,
I saw that the 45 percent of you had said that
you're starting your own companies or running your own companies.
So, I think that would be a wonderful, um, uh,
what we call product market fit,
for you, for the course and what your needs are.
Uh, the course is basically, um, er,
gonna be uh team-based and focused on delivering a go-to-market strategy.
So, without further ado,
uh, let me introduce Lynda.
Yeah, great to be with all of you and very excited that
you have interest in the Global Entrepreneurial Marketing program.
I've been very excited to be a part of this program now for,
um, over 15 years,
and what's exciting about it to me,
is the fact that we help people who perhaps have never
had any formal education or formal background in
the marketing area get all the basic elements that they
need to ultimately create a go to market plan for the company,
for the new product, through new offering,
as well as if they're in an organization,
understand what's going on with marketing in a way that they can really contribute.
So, what we're gonna be going through today is what makes
marketing and an entrepreneurial environment different.
Um, we will also be, uh,
diving into some marketing fundamentals,
just so you have an idea of how we kind of think about marketing, and then finally,
we'll do a high level view of what a go-to-market strategy actually includes.
Um, at one point, they said can you, yo,
tell them everything you would tell them, that, yo,
they would learn in- in the gem program,
and it's like, ah, yeah,
I'd need like 20 sessions to do it,
that is which gem is all about.
So, uh, jumping in that,
just a little bit of background,
you heard my bio, uh,
seems it was just a little bit dated,
but the last company that I was formerly in an op-,
in an operational role, Chief Strategy Officer,
Chief Marketing Officer was Twilio,
which was a platform based for developers which was an amazing experience,
and now I am actively advising and consulting for a number of companies,
one bad is especially fun is Misty,
which is a robotics company based on AI and,
uh, some really deep learning techniques.
So, super fun, and I will bring that into the classroom.
So, you have an opportunity to learn a little bit about what we're doing with
robotics at the same time as
learning what we're doing with entrepreneurial marketing there.
Um, let me turn it back over to Vic,
uh, for her to give you her background.
Perfect. Thank you Lynda.
So, uh, my background basically are three major buckets, and, um,
starts with corporate er, the corporate America,
so to speak, and academia and entrepreneurial ecosystem.
What I bring to the table is just ah both success and
failure in a number of ah entrepreneurial ventures.
Ah, as mentioned, this is my sixth startup,
and I would say, uh,
there have been so- ups and down, each of those,
uh I- I would imagine that the,
uh, the most I can bring to table that, uh,
is when we raise $17 million, and, uh,
frankly, I think without product-market fit,
it was not actually a good thing.
Um, and also, I bring to the table,
a lot of mental shift that I've had a lot of experience,
adv- uh, advising small,
and early startups and understanding of global perspective as I've lived in Asia for,
uh, I guess a latter part of the decade, and,
um, without spending too much time,
you'll get to know us throughout the quarter, uh,
if you were to join our class, uh,
but we will go straight into the agenda as we,
uh, we realize that time is short.
Awesome. But the other, uh,
one other comment is one thing you'll find with the classes it is very interactive.
We love to have you be able to engage with us that you,
you'll have an opportunity to ask all the questions that you have,
but also learn from each other,
because we have a fair number of people in the program that either have experience,
having been in an entrepreneurial or intrapreneurial organization um,
or they're just starting to get into one,
so lots of opportunity to learn from your peers.
So, let's jump to the next slide,
and I thought it might be useful to first just start off with what is marketing?
Because a lot of the people that come into the gem program actually have never
had a marketing course or a marketing activity before.
And so, when you think about marketing,
there's some wonderful definitions out there.
When I first did the- the quick Google search on this,
it cracked me up, how many different ways marketing has been defined.
This one for being a consumer,
actually resonated with me.
Marketing is helping your customers understand how
much they need something they never knew they needed.
Which quite frankly is how you sometimes feel ah as a consumer.
But the one I really believe in is the next one,
if you'll flip it over there [NOISE],
is this one that is much broader.
Marketing today is finally customer focused.
Social media made that happen [NOISE].
Markets are once again conversations.
Marketing is about knowing the market,
creating the right product to this point about product market fit,
creating desire for that product,
and then letting the right people know you have it.
What I think of marketing,
I think of it as a very broad end to end process which I'll touch on in a moment,
but it is this idea of coming up with
right ideas and then really moving them to market by having the right go to market plan,
and again, that's what we want to make sure you leave
with after being apart of the gem program.
Let's click over to the next slide.
All right, so, we've just talked about what marketing is.
What does it mean to be entrepreneurial marketing?
Well, the reality is it is based on all the fundamentals of traditional marketing,
and we're gonna give you a sampling of that across, uh, the course.
But it is also about this mindset that comes,
it's defined by this orientation.
And if you've ever been in an entrepreneurial organization
and as the poll showed there's a fair number of you, uh, 45 percent,
that are actually starting your own companies,
there is this whole idea of,
it's about moving fast,
you don't have time to stand still.
It's about being agile,
being able to pivot and constantly change what you're doing from a marketing perspective,
it's about leveraging the passion that the organization has because that's
so much of what people buy in the early days,
and it's also about being creative,
which I'll touch on in a moment.
Now, if you're someone already in a formal organization,
and you want to be a part of innovation,
what we oftentimes call intrapreneurial,
all of that applies as well,
even though the organization may be older,
maybe more mature, whenever you're bringing that new idea,
that new concept to market,
it goes back to all the principles of being in that entrepreneurial environment,
moving fast, being agile,
the list we just covered.
It's also focused on establishing a company in an industry or a product in a segment,
and it's about growing rapidly.
So, all of those things change the way you fundamentally think about marketing.
Because marketing very traditionally has more of a planning horizon to it.
We get comfortable with longer windows of being able to define campaigns,
of being able to put things out into the market.
You can't do it when you're in this entrepreneurial mode.
Now, there are challenges to that point of being creative.
Most entrepreneurial ventures face
this unusual thing called no-one knows my company or my product or my service.
Uh, usually you're in a very early stage of product or service,
so you're trying to make sure it does have
that product market fit and if not how do we move forward,
and then a lot of times your resources are very modest,
which just comes back to again,
you're in that very early stage,
you're not necessarily earning revenue yet,
so you have to figure out how to market in
the most creative way that you can. Uh, [OVERLAPPING].
Very quickly add to that,
um, I in- in,
my journey as an entrepreneur anyway,
I'm always short on time,
think should have happened yesterday and short on cash.
So, this is exactly what we're bringing to the table.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, I thought it'll also be interesting to share with you,
I got three questions very commonly,
if you ju-jump to the next slide.
I get three questions from
the entrepreneurial organizations that I advise and that I work with.
Uh. First one is, when do I hire for marketing?
The next one is, well, who do I hire?
First? When? And then what level do I hire in at?
So, I thought it might be interesting just to touch on that briefly
here before we get into the marketing fundamentals.
Let's start off with, when do I hire for marketing?
You can switch to the next slide.
Typically, people start investing in marketing when the product is ready
for that broader use versus
just that feedback loop which is really important in the early days,
but now you want to get the word out,
and you want people to really start coming to you and wanting to learn more.
You hire for marketing when revenue is now a or the key objective,
you have to or building up numbers and when a in a network but now really you are
being looked at as you know what is that key result that we need to have,
well, it's either more money or it's more users um of a platform?
But it's when you need to really now generate start generating mass.
And it's also when that current staff you have just can't cover the marketing effort.
What I found in some wonderful new start-up says,
it just happens to be that the founder had a little bit of
marketing or someone they hired have done marketing before,
and that they're actually in the earliest days able to handle it.
But now there'll be a point where oh, wow.
Yeah, maybe someone has really done this done this before,
let's start looking at bringing him in the staff.
Next question, if you could switch over.
Um. Then it comes in then to, who do I hire?
And this is just my point of view but it's worked for me.
Generalists are golden.
In those earliest days when you're hiring for
marketing finding someone that has pretty broad experience,
not just focused on one area can be super helpful.
I also find that the marketing model drives it,
um we'll talk a little bit about
the marketing model in a moment but sales driven revenue,
well then you want someone who knows lead generation, sales enablement.
If it's marketing driven revenue,
then you want somebody who knows brand and campaign orientation.
If it's about a platform play,
you want someone who typically knows developers
and if it's about growth hacking that's the model you're
following and marketing then you want someone who
is uber smart on the online and digital side of things.
Hire someone who can get from A to Z with a little help,
you don't have time to train these folks.
Also find somebody who doesn't need an army reporting to them,
because we're talking lean moving fast,
and then if you have a technically steep product,
find someone who's technically steep as a marketer.
And then the last question,
which is what level do I hire in at?
Culture matters, avoid title creep,
too early and then you enable it,
don't enable your best early starters to be a part of the company.
Experienced level doesn't necessarily mean title, um,
and then finally churn will happen,
some people are just better in a beginning company.
These are also some of the topics we'll talk about during gem.
As you're thinking about the team that you need to form and Vic is amazing
when it comes to team-building and understanding organizational design,
we'll talk about this as well as we go through the program so you can be thinking
about how you might have to bring that marketing team together for your business.
Yes, and to that end I,
I do believe that in, uh, both,
um, research and my own experience,
there'll be different teams at different stages of an entrepreneurial endeavor.
So, therefore, um, keeping these things in mind that
experience is not actually equal title is really important as,
um, your first marketing CMO may not remain a CMO for a much much larger company.
All right. So, why to give you just a little bit of
view of how to think about entrepreneurial marketing.
Now, we're going to dive into just a few marketing fundamentals,
and these are fundamentals that we leverage across the program.
Um, the first one on the next slide really comes back to
this idea of this End-to-End View of marketing,
it's an ETE process.
Now, in a lot of companies all they think about
marketing is that kind of fourth column over,
it's all about it's just about demand generation,
how do you get me leads?
How do you get me more customers?
But in the most effective companies that I've been a part of or I've advised,
they take a much broader view of marketing.
Marketing is about the strategy and planning which you'll see
come out as we talk about the go-to-market plan you would put together.
They do own product in some capacity,
if they don't have product management reporting into them directly they are
an active participant in defining that product or service.
Demand generation is naturally a part of it,
you have to have that.
And then also now this idea of the customer marketing,
making sure that you have retention,
boy, I can tell you in startups.
One of the biggest challenges that they have when they go for
their next funding round is what was your retention rate?
So, if you don't think about that early on,
how do we take care of our customers?
It's not gonna happen.
Marketing plays a role across all of these parts of the spectrum,
and we'll show you through the various sessions how you do that.
[OVERLAPPING] She'll jump to an, uh.
Please Vic, and then jump to the next slide.
Just adding to that,
is really reducing the friction of how you get your customers to interact with
you and to you know either it's switching over or staying with you over time,
is a constant tests of this iterative way of thinking about how you market and what mark,
what exact product is going to be.
So, uh resonates with the end-to-end view of marketing.
Yeah. Now, we are going to talk just a little bit about more of
that demand generation column because it is so central to when you're an early startup,
it's one, it is one of the things you invest in probably the earliest in marketing,
um, the whole area of this demand generation.
Now, I joke with a lot of our students who come in from
a very technical background and I'll ask a question the first day,
how many of you, you know, believe in marketing?
What do you think marketing is?
And I, I always get the feedback,
oh it's that fluffy stuff but,
it's my personal mission at every- every time we run the gem program is for people
to leave with a great respect for
the marketing function because there really is a science around it.
But part of what you're doing in demand generation that is a science,
because you're moving people through what we call this hierarchy of effects,
taking people from being totally unaware of
a product all the way through to where there's an action,
whether that's purchased or sign up or whatever the right conversion is.
And there are layers to building that natural understanding,
getting them to that purchase point.
They have to be aware,
then you'd have to feed them with enough knowledge that they they understand who you are,
what you stand for,
and you can get to that point where they actually like you,
and then have a preference over the competition and
then finally we get the conviction that they want to engage
with you and there are marketing tactics that we use at each stage of this.
Now, some people also call this the funnel,
taking people from awareness to consideration to action,
that terms, you hear that a lot within a- a sales organization perspective.
So, we'll talk through the program as well,
but how do you get people through this hierarchy of effects?
And again, in a startup world,
pick chance that out there that no one knows who you are,
so you need to really pay attention how do you get people there. Next slide please.
This profession called marketing is really a bit of psychology,
ah, ethnography, data scientists, decision-making.
So, its- its is a lot that's encompass
into this thing called marketing which is fascinating.
Yeah and that's a great tee up for the next slide.
One of the things that I actually did in my education,
did have lot of psy-psychology courses,
a lot of sociology courses.
And one of the things that you really
resonated that is when you're thinking about marketing,
what you're really trying to do is help people form these perceptions,
and so the way a perception is formed,
is first it comes in to this idea of a sensory registry,
that's when you just first been exposed,
you saw the billboard, you saw the ad.
But it doesn't stick,
I mean there's just something back there that is familiar if you see it again.
And what we're doing with this marketing process is strengthening that signals so we
can get into that short-term memory and if we as marketers have done our job really well,
we get all the way into that long-term memory where
the real value comes because then you've got word of mouth.
Someone comes up and says, "Hey,
I'm looking for x ", and a person goes, "Oh, yeah,
there's this company out there I've heard of their awesome,
um you should go check them out".
So, part of this marketing effort is tapping into the psychology of people,
getting into their minds and if you turn to the next sli-slide,
it is not an easy thing to do,
the average human attention span is only seven seconds,
and that's 1 second less than a goldfish.
So, a marketer's job it's not ne- necessarily an easy job.
Yeah. It's kind of like the attention economy
that we're all vying for people's attention,
and as a new product is a little bit hard to do,
unless you do a really good job of planning and marketing.
Absolutely.
Now, to try to help with that whole idea of how do you get into the- the mind of someone,
how do you work through that- that- that- that-
that stages of sensory short-term or long-term,
we use a tactic that we call,
our strategy will call Integrated Marketing,
which is really this idea that you have to use
a whole variety of tactics to be able to do it,
and that's because we all learn differently,
we all have different attention spans for
different types of content, different types of media.
So, we actually will spend three of the sessions talking about demand creation,
and getting you familiar enough with each of the tactics that are out there,
and there are many more than what you see on these bubbles, that's just a, uh,
sampling of them, so that you can start thinking about your own company,
about your own work and your own target audience,
and really starting to think about,
what's gonna be most effective to get people through
that hierarchy and get into that long-term memory.
[NOISE] Alright.
So, we'll also walk through this in the program.
There are different types of marketing, uh, um,
and these are kind of that- the- the old traditional words for it if you will.
There's the idea of B2B marketing,
and this is really about catering to businesses.
Here your target audience is the business,
as well as the buyer that is internal to that company.
So, if you're selling an enterprise software product,
your chances are you want to get to the person who actually uses it,
but probably also there's a CIO that's involved,
there's a CFO involved,
um, that you have to include.
So, multiple audiences that you're catering to inside.
Then you have the world of B2C,
and this is really about catering to consumers,
we all are the recipient of that target audience, the consumer.
One we care a lot about now,
a lot of startups, uh,
a lot of intrapreneurial efforts going after this idea of B2B2C.
Here you're catering to the businesses that cater to consumers.
Oftentimes, you also have to cater to the consumer so you get both the push and the pull,
and your target audience then tends to be the business,
the buyer, as an individual again in the consumer.
And then, the last one,
you're seeing a lot more activity around in terms of types of marketing,
is this idea of B2D,
which is about catering to developers.
Here you're really focusing on
that individual developer to get them excited about what you're doing.
And there are different ways that you approach marketing in each of these types,
and so we'll be going through that as well.
Um, from figuring out what
the right product market fit is to how you're creating that demand,
how do you create great experiences for customer loyalty,
we'll make sure it relates back to each of these types of marketing.
And to add to that end, there are, uh,
instances where you may have multiple markets.
So, your customer may be,
you know, one to five different customer types.
Uh, what we'll be using are some cases that'll be underlying all,
uh, er, the different business models,
and illustrate how other people have done it for,
uh, for instance in the pa- in the past,
and some new ways to novel ways of thinking about being
creative about marketing to so many different constituencies.
Yeah, and one of the things that both Vic and I will work
very hard is bringing in our own experience as well.
So, one of the things I love about this program,
is because I'm actually hands-on practitioner even today.
I love sharing what I'm doing,
getting your feedback on it,
but trying to bring in those real-world examples as well, uh,
from my own past experience [OVERLAPPING].
Touching on that idea of platforms.
Um, so, when we talk about the B2D play with developers,
generally what you'll find is it does surround this idea of platform plays,
which is the fact that we've now all realized that
sometimes the greatest source of innovation is
outside the walls of your own organization or company.
We'll also be talking about platform plays,
not only from the perspective of developers,
but how you build up a platform play so that, you know,
you've got the chicken and egg thing you're trying to solve in terms of, okay,
for this platform to be effective,
I need both of these types of audiences,
how do I bring in both end?
So, we'll be spending some solid time on
platform plays which you see more and more companies adopting.
Alright. Going to another,
uh, another way to look at all of this.
So, I offered up the traditional types of Marketing, B2B, B2C.
Through my experience, one of the other things that I've realized is that, wow,
and I hate to say I'm dating myself,
this whole thing called the Internet changed my world, uh,
e-commerce changed my world,
and what you start finding is because e-com is a vehicle for not only B2C but B2B, B2B2C,
that if a product is hard to convey the value for what the price tag is,
or it's hard to get up started and ba- uh,
started and running, then you have to have humans involved, salespeople involved.
It doesn't matter if you're B2B or B2C,
you'll think about any phone plan.
You're the reason why so many of the carriers have ah pop-up stores,
have full-fledged stores as you go to their website
and trying to figure out what role over minutes mean and how many family members can buy.
I mean, there's so much complication and a plan you have to talk to a human.
That's a B2C company,
but they act a lot like a B2B organization,
in fact from the standpoint of having sales.
So, I look at that as a sales driven revenue model, regardless.
Now, on the same token, you know,
if it's easy to buy and get started and it's easy to see the value, then yo,
chances are you're going to be selling it through an e-com channel,
it's going to be largely marketing driven revenue,
and again it doesn't matter whether or not it's yo a consumer play or business play,
an old time example for me is Yammer.
They completely disrupted the platform business,
the social business bit, uh,
platform business that Jive was in,
by making it so easy to buy and so easy to see the value,
but they were B2B play.
So, when we think about this traditional models,
they're always important to come back to because
so much of the world thinks of it that way,
but we'll also be tapping in and talking about how is it that
B2B and B2C sometimes really overlap in the tactics that you use?
Next slide. An understanding whether you are fitting a sales driven revenue model,
a marketing driven revenue model,
this platform play or growth hacking.
It all drives marketing's role, the focus,
the team that you build,
the skills that you need and the budgets that you have.
And then, I'm just gonna share one last ah super important ah fundamental.
and this dates back if any of you ever heard of the, uh, .com.bust era
You'll recognize this little sock puppet dude down there.
That was our biggest problem.
We didn't follow this rule.
Your CAC cannot be greater than the lifetime value of a customer.
It- it's just an out of balance business value,
you'll never make any money and CAC is that Customer Acquisition Costs. And guess what?
Marketing plus sales we are that Customer Acquisition Cost.
What you wanna do is ensure that your lifetime value is always
greater than the amount you're spending to acquire that customer.
So, we'll talk a lot about that as well and how you make sure
that you have a balanced business model all the way from top to bottom.
All right. I'm gonna stop, I'm gonna turn it over to you Vic now to drive this home.
Thank you. Okay. So, next we're going to talk about, er, the globe- er,
go-to-market strategy, which, um,
i- in our course,
is really the- the final piece,
and we bring all the pieces that we will,
the core marketing pieces that man, uh,
creation into a framework that is a clear blueprint of actions.
So, a golden mar- uh,
market strategy is defined as an action plan that
specifies how a company would reach customers and achieve competitive advantage.
The purpose of a GTM strategy is provide for blueprints,
for delivering a product or service to the end customer,
taking into account factors such as pricing and distribution.
In other words, is really a program for your customer to say, hey,
I would like to buy something from you,
and also, um, er, the experience,
and you would like for your customer should have from the-
the click that will get you the- the customer,
all the way to the renewal process,
how easy is it for that customer to get to
you and to help you generate the revenue that you're needed.
Yeah. And one of the things I'll add on on why we have put
so much emphasis on understanding how to create a go to market plan in the program,
um it's actually two fold.
Yo, first of all, it is often the first thing someone asks you.
Yo, well, what is your go to market,
your strategy, you know,
what's the plan that you have and then,
kind of sit back and you go oh,
that is get it- I better go figure out what that is.
But the other thing is I have actually worked in a number of organizations now,
where the go-to-market strategy was build it and they will come,
um and that can sometimes work for a short period of time but then all of a sudden,
when the numbers are there and people are looking for where the numbers are,
whether it's number of users or the revenue,
you end up in a situation where it was oh yeah, yo,
I guess I have to go back now and create that strategy.
And we do measure what, uh,
we do treasure what we measure,
and, uh, a lot of entrepreneurial marketing is about that,
is the analytics and making decisions based on the numbers that come back,
and you, if- if this particular way to sell a product,
it does not work or this particular way of pricing something doesn't work,
we have to go back to the- the planning to come up with the
second perhaps 2.0 of your go to market, market strategy.
Um, how a- an organization will
benefit from go-to-market strategy is both internal and external.
Um, it's a internal facing activity where,
whether it is engineering, R and D,
sales and marketing all have to understand where we're going with this thing.
And it's also an external, because, er,
you'll- you'll have to include your customers into thinking about how they would
situate your products as we are inundated with so many products these days.
To put it- it into a place where they can draw back to
perhaps long-term memory that will draw
out when perhaps they're looking for that part- uh,
particular product or service.
So, some of the things that I like to highlight is that it does have,
it helps to establish your path for growth.
It maximizes your competitive opportunity as very iterative,
so it's not that we just make one plan and go with it,
but we will continue to revisit the same plan,
so that it will reduce your time to market,
it reduces costs as we're all short of time and money,
and it increases the ability for us to adapt to change to
have a clear communication also externally.
So, some of the key questions in the Go-to-Market would
be what- what- what is the market you want to pursue?
What is your target audience?
Um, who are the- the customers you're gonna be selling to?
What are some of the personas?
How do they behave?
What is their demographic?
And what is your offering?
Probably one of the most important questions is, how would you,
um, create value for your customers? What are you selling?
Um, and the next question is,
what are the channels that will get you to the customers?
We looked at the various di- different ways and different, um,
these models whether there's a B2B, B2B to C2D.
There are so many different ways that we can distribute this product these days.
We have to think thoroughly about what those channels maybe
in terms of sales and distribution, uh, creating demand,
but also as Lynda had said,
if we cannot keep a customer,
how do we provide the customer service to
also be able to keep the customers that we acquire?
Um, and pricing is a very big topic.
We're gonna spend one session on it probably not gonna be
enough but pricing is how much you would charge the customer?
How would you, um, er, er,
maybe shifted based on the size of your,
your, uh, the deal?
There are so many questions and we,
we have to answer in order for us to have a well thought out go- Go-To-Market strategy.
And last but not least,
obviously how do you position your market?
Uh, how do you position your product in the marketplace?
What is your unique value proposition?
How do you differentiate from other products that are very similar?
And potentially how do you have maybe coopetition?
We'll spend a little bit of time in our quarter to talk about that as well.
And so if you take, uh,
the Global Entrepreneurial Marketing Program,
the way they have structured the series of lectures and topics is actually they
take you through everything that you need
to answer all those questions that Vic just went through.
If you decide not to take the program,
well now you have the questions you need to answer to create your go to market,
uh, your go to market approach.
So, hopefully that will provide some instant value for you.
Excellent. Um, you know, uh,
the Go-To-Market strategy is really a time and space exercise.
Um, when you first introduce the,
the product is gonna have a certain set of,
er, answers to the questions we just post and the growth phase obviously that's very,
very important and when you get to the maturity phase and
then perhaps you might want to pivot and as your, uh,
product declines into a phase where,
um, you don't need as much marketing,
uh, and you may want to consider other products and services to supplement.
Uh, as Salesforce says you can imagine at first we're going to be
no software but now they have totally embraced this, um, platform business.
Uh, they- they go through the Trailblazer , uh,
and Dreamforce, uh- uh,
uh, activities that they- they do now.
Um, of course, there are
potentially two ways that you can look at the various markets that you want to market,
and for each of these,
you must also answer all those questions that we had just posted.
Who's your target? Who are your customers?
What is that pricing going to be?
How you gonna reach them?
And how are you gonna sustain them?
Okay? With that, um,
should we open it up for questions?
Lindah you have anything else to add?
No. I just say, you know, um,
Global- the Global Entrepreneurial Marketing Program I think is super fun program,
there's a lot of opportunity for you to, you know,
really dig in and learn not only, uh,
from a we-provide, the presenters that come in as well as your,
your fellow students to add.
You know, if it's important to you to have the right Go-To-Market strategy.
Again, whether you're a brand new startup or you're trying to
bring something new out from a more mature company,
um, I think you're gonna learn what you need from us.
Okay.
Wonderful. Thank you both Victoria and Lynda for this,
uh, fascinating brief and- and- and a very fast overview of so many interesting concepts.
I- I- I'd like to open with questions coming from our audience talking about
the early days of new ventures and
specifically a question came in from a participant who's wondering,
how do you convince a highly technical founder,
a CEO who happens to have a- a PhD in electrical engineering.
How do you convince an individual like that coming from
hardcore scientific background to invest in marketing?
How would you go about doing that?
I think she can answer that.
Yeah, I can definitely jump in on that one.
Uh, been there, done that multiple times now.
Um, so there are a number of ways that it happens,
um, first of all, you know,
if you're already very in the company and you're trying to convince them it's now time,
um, because of the way that technical founders thinking you know,
you have to bring facts to 'em,
you have to, you know,
build a case if you will,
that shows the why, uh,
behind it and working with engineers and
developers that's one of the key things I always do,
is I always to try to answer the why behind we need to do it and why we need to do it.
So, part of it is building up that- that case
for why it's important now at this juncture in the company.
Um, it's also about earning their trust though and, you know, as I said you know,
one of my goals in the program is to get over
the- the- the perception of people have of marketing just fluff and it's
a waste of time so that they really understand how it could benefit
that business and earning that trust with the technical founder is super important.
You know, that you understand the product,
that you understand the market,
that you've talked to the customers,
and so what you're really representing is something that he can trust or she can trust,
I should say as well.
Um, I'll tell you, the other way it happens very honestly is if it's
a company that's already gone out and it's got angel investors,
series A, maybe sometimes even this side is series B,
uh, the VCs will,
uh, definitely push on that.
Uh, there will be a point where they'll say,
"You need to get someone in here who knows marketing."
Um, and what will oftentimes drive that is that,
uh, the numbers aren't making it, uh,
the projections aren't there,
and they realized that the- the product itself is not just going to,
uh, bring the people in.
So, uh, there is the do it internally,
build the trust, answer the why,
um, or it will come from the outside.
Um, to that end also, uh,
in my experience, um,
technical co-founders often a- we- we- we
can appeal them through logic and basically, um,
if you have a lot of customer stories that can
help illustrate the point of we do need to do marketing.
Uh, I've had a lot of investors breathing down my neck [LAUGHTER]
and frankly I was not a technical founder or co-founder, uh,
but we did realize very quickly that we had to bring somebody in from marketing, er,
because the metrics just didn't show that we were growing or we're
not selling the product in- in the way that we had planned for it.
Does that answer your questions?
Yes. Thank you. Er, my- my next question is about social media and specifically,
er, wi- with social media being so prevalent in today's world,
does it makes sense to launch marketing activities on social media
before the product or service is ready to launch and- and if so would you also,
er, do it in organic fashion or a paid fashion and then
perhaps you can talk about when do you start investing in social media?
Okay. Um, maybe I'll have to get started at it first.
Uh, in a lot of my startup, I basically would,
um allocate a very small amount of money just to do product vali-, er, validation.
Does anybody want this thing bey- beyond my group of friends so to speak?
And once you establish a little bit of that, um,
I think with social media it is a- is not a very costly way to just get early about,
er, validation of your products and services and
at which point maybe it can be quite smart about collecting data.
For instance, you may, um,
start offering this product or service to a certain group and
watch those metrics and maybe open it up for discussion say,
"Hey, you guys are the early users,
what would you change about this?
What do you love about this and what do you hate about this?"
So, um, I do thin- think that marketing
would not be marketing without social media or any kind of,
[LAUGHTER] um, social platform. Lynda?
Yeah. I think, you know, what I would add to that is, um,
my first response, uh,
to the individual would be,
well who's your target audience?
Um, because in my experience social media has,
er, different roles to play for a company.
It will always be there but there are some audiences say,
"You just can't reach through social media,
it's not where they live,
it's not where they get their- their information."
And so, using social media for that, you know,
type of a target audience is just not gonna be effective, um,
there are other audiences with- where it's like yeah that is where they hangout and you
get down to the particular social media vehicle be it a Facebook or,
you know, Twitch TV,
or you- you figure out,
you know, what the right vehicles are.
The other thing in this kinda place off what Vic was saying,
you also in a social media strategy need to define what
your objectives are and what Vic was really, you know,
talking about is, you know,
figuring out from almost that kind of market research perspective of,
do you have that right product market fit?
Are you getting the right features into the product?
Uh, you may find that social if they- if that's not where they
live from a perspective of learning and demand creation that social for you is,
um, a channel for customer support and that's really where it's at.
So, you know, what I look at a startup,
and, do you use social or not?
First thing that I do is go back to who's the target audience?
And is this where they live, um,
in terms of getting information,
being persuaded to move through that hierarchy of effects,
then I sit back and say, "Okay,
what do we really want to accomplish with social?"
Uh, which could be market validation
or it could be customer support or it could be that demand creation.
Then I go out and figure out what are the right tactics?
Thank you. The next question has to do with
moving from the early days to I think the growth phase.
And- and we mentioned earlier the generalists are golden in the early days,
when do you know the time to start hiring for technical expertise in marketing?
Lynda.
Yeah. Um, so, you know,
first of all one of the immediate signals that I see in accompany that it is time to, uh,
bring on marketing is the fact that, you know,
they're looking at what their next growth numbers are gonna be and
they do an internal assessment and they realize okay, you know,
it's either gonna take more bandwidth than when we've been able to put
forward to it because we've had a person to adapt plus their- their day job,
um, or they realized that they don't have
the specific expertise in the area of marketing.
Maybe let's take an example,
if a company is going to drive,
um, heavy e-Commerce, uh, interaction.
If that is the, uh,
the model that they've picked,
chances are they're gonna need someone that's heavy into digital,
heavy into analytics, and if they look around the room and they don't have that,
then that's gonna tell them,
you know, it's time to hire.
Uh, the other thing, you know,
that I would say is in terms of technical and you can look at technical different ways,
one of the mistakes that I do see companies make is that they will be
a technical product and they don't hire a technical resource within marketing, um,
and by that I mean, um,
I just helped a company that I advise put in their, uh,
CMO and it is as a product that's being sold to
engineers as particularly in the QA space.
And we needed to have someone that
came from that background to actually be able to do the marketing efforts.
So, the- the gentleman has stepped in,
uh, you know, engineering background,
he has had to run QA before has been- wanted to do marketing
so his whole career has been in marketing but he comes
with that level of technical expertise.
Just e- exactly what Lynda said plus a little bit,
uh, more than I like to add is that, uh, when a, uh,
marketing is not just something that happens, uh,
It's not an activity that needs to be looked at on a contingency basis,
meaning that maybe once a week, we looked at metrics.
Two, "Hey, we've got to be looking at metrics every hour."
That's when you really need to bring in a professional to
manage that and to make sense of what's really happening.
Excellent, and- and that ques the next question regarding
metrics and data and- and the LTV versus [NOISE] the customer acquisition cost.
How do you define,
how do you make sure to do the right,
you do the- the definition and the measuring of
the customer acquisition costs in the early days
when data is not readily available, right?
How do you- how do you guide the management team
as- as you come in with a recommendation?
Whether it be a certain,
uh, dollar amount or a percentage of budget?
How- how do you deal with those questions?
Yeah. It- it's never tha- it's never easy.
Um, the reality is in the earliest days,
you are dealing with that lack of data.
So, there are different ways that you can approach it.
First of all, you can look to see if there are companies that are
similar to yours or selling in the same product category,
and what has the traditional CAC been for them,
traditional lifetime value been for them.
Um, an example was- I was working with a company that was in a high-end, ah,
electronics products space and we were able to go out and just research online.
You know, what the average CAC was for selling
a high-end electronics product via the e-Comm channel.
So, there is that kind of data out there,
um, that you can tap into in the early days.
Um, also you can do a bottoms-up approach,
which is looking at all the vehicles that you want to use and what
the worth price of that would be and that will
start giving you an idea of what the cost of acquisition would be,
um, from the pure marketing perspective if it's
sales-driven revenue then you also would bring
in what is the cost of having a sales team on-board,
is at one person two people.
And so, you can do some bottom-up calculations in the early days as well.
[NOISE] Um, in the early days,
it's kind of like art and science um,
it- it's a lot of art [LAUGHTER] and creativeness that,
er, gives you some signals.
Uh, [NOISE] some things that have worked for me personally,
is going into communities and talk to other founders
[NOISE] in your own space and they can give you some guidance,
is not science but it is some guidance.
Excellent. Thank you, er,
another set of- of questions are coming regarding innovation in marketing, um,
a- and I wonder if fro- from your very strategic approach,
you can share with us some of
the innovative approaches to marketing that you've recently seen and,
and how would that be,
ho- how do people know to identify
thi- these next innovations in [NOISE] marketing that can
often give companies the competitive advantages as they compete against
their, uh, peer competitors, right?
Well, I think that the biggest threats that I've seen as of late in marketing,
that's kind of the next wave,
is everything around analytics.
Uh, and there are, you know, a lot of companies
now that are leveraging AI, um, and deep learning, ah,
because they've got the data around their customers and I know AI is
a way overused term and has so many different meanings out there today.
But it's really this idea of leveraging all of the data you have around you,
that can give you a huge competitive advantage over someone,
else if you learn how to harness that data,
er, and put it to work.
Yeah. Um, I'd like to bring that also home to the fact that we are um,
ma- marketing as a multi-discipline approach to being
both [NOISE] behavioral scientists, uh, to psychology,
so it- your customers will be human beings so tha- that data will help
inform at the- the end of their designing these experiences will potentially help you,
um, get the competitive edge.
Thank you. Ah, th- the next question is around
the- the perhaps tension between product management,
product marketing, and marketing.
Er, product management, er,
in recent years has come to the front in terms of involvement in organization
and are there tensions built in
between marketing team and-and- and product marketing,
product management, who owns the Go-To-Market plan?
Is the product management?
Is- is it product marketing?
How do the various individuals in these roles work best together?
Um, I'II take a step at this i- is
a very complex question and it's different with every stage of an organization.
Um, you know, in the- in the early stages they will be dis- there will not be distinct,
you know, product management to program management to other, ah,
aspects of the team but as you grow um,
again I tru- truly believe that a Go-To-Market strategy is
a plan that's internally facing and externally facing and
everyone pretty much has to own a piece if not all of
it being cognizant that what I do today will affect what you do tomorrow, Lynda.
Yeah. I think it has a lot to do also with the players that you've hired in the company.
Um, where you have a strong, uh,
leader in Marketing, um,
the CMO the VP of Marketing whatever the title level is.
Um, if they believe in this construct of marketing is an end-to-end process,
they're gonna step in and take it over um,
and own the Go-To-Market, um, because they get
how that is directly tied to what they do at every stage.
So, um, I think that's strength of leadership in the marketing area,
um, drives a lot of that.
If that marketing leader, um,
that you've hired is more of
a demand creation person that's really where the sweet spot is,
that's what they wake up and love to do,
then chances are it'll be someone else in the organization,
maybe they had a product management that takes
on that umbrella of I wanna own the Go-To-Market.
Sometimes it's even the,
the CEO or the founder,
[NOISE] you know, in a young company.
In terms of that friction, yo know,
which is kind of a second question under
the question between product management and product marketing,
um, what I have found is that, you know,
if product management and product marketing can really form a team, uh,
relationship which they need to,
then you can get away,
you can get away from there being, um,
any problems between the two organizations.
If there is a dynamic or product management feels that, you know,
[NOISE] they're kind of over important because they're
driving how a product is built and we're working
with engineering and that product marketing is just kind of this afterthoughts,
the fluffy part, then you're gonna have problems.
And so again, you have that opportunity through
organizational design to make sure you avoid that problem.
And also in MS&E,
we've seen a lot of students who go into marketing and with that analytics background,
it's, um, it's quite useful for them to have the same language. Moving forward.
Yeah.
I would like to wrap up by asking both of
you to talk about the individuals who of course,
is appropriate who should take this course really as as- as you look at, er,
at your experienced teaching it before and teaching here at Stanford in general,
ah, who extracts value out of it
an- and what are- what should they expect to get out of it?
Of course, we've covered a lot of materials today.
But, what is- how do we,
uh, answer that question?
Um, ah, I- I believe the people who get the
most out of this course are really people who have had very little exposure to marketing.
Um, if you have had a role in marketing or
you've taken marketing courses in the GSB or, um,
a business school, this would be- this- you have incremental knowledge versus a "Oh,
my gosh, all these aha moments.".
Yeah, a- and to trade off of that I- I get very excited by the students that we've had in
the program in the past that are- are now in
companies and you'll- they'll come back and say,
"Wow, you know, I learned so much during that program,
I've been able to actually had apply it and had I not gone to that gone through GEM,
I never would have had really any exposure to marketing."
Those are the ones that seem to come out and are most excited about what they learned.
If you'd have one marketing class,
I think we can definitely build on it,
um, but to a fixed point,
if you're someone who already has a marketing degree or you've been working, you know,
15 years in the field, um,
we probably can't go deep enough in any
of the topics to give you what you're really looking for.
Excellent. Thank you so much and,
and certainly we have not,
we have not been able to answer all the questions that were asked in
today's webinar but we will followup with someone answers from you.
We typically correlate questions that are submitted.
Both Victoria and Lynda,
we'll get back to us with, with specific answers. [OVERLAPPING].
Yeah, fantastic questions by the way.
I've been watching them rolling in and it's been very hard not to jump in and
answer those actually right here, uh, by text.
Yes. And- and thank you so much Lynda again for joining us today. [NOISE]
Of course.
Absolutely.
Thank you for participation.
Thank you.
All right. Buh-bye.
Buh-bye.
Bye everyone.